رغم الدعم العسكريه المتواصل والمتزايده
لاوكرانيا باخر ما توصلت اليه التكنولوجيا
العسكريه الغربيه الا ان البلاد التي تخوض
حربا معريه منذ اواخر فبراير الماضي تعتمد
في مواجهتها للقوات الروسيه المتفوقه
على سلاح قديم وقديم جدا وللدقه سلاح يعود
الى الحكمه السوفياتيه يوم كانت اوكرانيا
جزءا من الاتحاد السوفيتي وهنا يبرز مهم
كيف يمكن الانتصار في حروب المستقبل
باعتماد على معدات من القرن العشرين
ولماذا تلجاكيف لسلاح المتهالك الاجابه
ببساطه ان غالبيه تترسانه اوكرانيا
العسكريه يترسانه روسيه او سوفيه»
والتي صنعت في الستينات القرن الماضي
بمدينه خاركيز بالاضافه الى صاروخ كروز كي
اتش 35
اضافه بالطبع الى السلاح الخفيف وخصوصا
الكلاشنكوف وهو سلاح قديم النسبي ومتوسطا
ومدرعات سوفياتيه قديمه بطيئه وتستهلك
وقودا بشكل كبير
والقطارات المتهلكه والتي تعود بدورها الى
حكمه المعسكر الشرقي وحلف وارسو الذي سقط
من خلال الاتحاد السوفيتي وتفتته
من الحكمه السوفياتيه القديمه الى الغربيه
الحديثه لكن اوكرانيا وعلى ضوء امدادها
باسلحه غربيه حديثه بينها مدافعها
ومنظومه صواريخ هيمارس اضافه الى منظومات
صواريخ المانيه متقدمه تثبت فعاليه كبيره
في ساحه القتال مدعومه بصور واحداثيات
تقدمها الاقمار الصناعيه